"By definition, only the Coward is capable of the highest heroism" - David Gemmell
For the coward fights, despite his weak nature.
Prince Allant, the son of King Allant, travels to the Boletarian Palace under the name "Ostrava", in order to hide his true identity.
The scourge has devastated the kingdom and as the player sets out to kill the arch demons,
Ostrava fights through the Boletarian Palace with the sole intention:
To find his father and to dispel the rumors that his father, the king
has become a demon.
Ostrava is wise, but weak. He's lived a pampered life yet
he takes up the legendary weapons of a hero and attempts to fight his way to his father's throne.
We first found Ostrava on a ledge, with no way back. He was surrounded by Dreglings, which were waiting to cut him down.
"That was a bold jump, a surprise indeed. Well, now that you are here, pray thee, fend off these dreglings."
"My thanks for your brave rescue. I'm Ostrava of Boletaria."
We fought the Dreglings off as Ostrava watched. We can tell from the way he talks, he almost assumes...
it's our duty to rescue him.
This will change, as Ostrava continues to discover her hopeless ease in the world around him.
Much of his time is spent within the Nexus. Like many others, he has trouble finding the courage to leave.
Ostrava, like you, is bound to the Nexus.
Die in human form and you'll resurrect in an ethereal soul form.
Demon souls allow you to keep your sanity while you're in this soul form, and a mature demon soul can restore your corporeal human form.
But die in soul form and that's the end. You'll lose both your sanity and your life:
resurrecting as a black phantom. That's why death is such a fearsome thing.
That's why Ostrava is afraid to leave the Nexus. But he came here for a reason.
"At it's peak,
Boletaria was a grand kingdom.
The King, his knights, and his subjects were modest and plain,
but also steadfast and compassionate. In the distant Southern Kingdom,
Boletaria was known as 'paradise on Earth'.
But look at what has become of us now... I refuse to believe, that this is what father wished for our great land."
Ostrava progresses slowly, but surely.
Always in fear of losing his life, but driven to reach his father's keep. With your help,
what would have been impossible becomes a possibility. "Over here!
It's me, Ostrava.
Look at me, again surrounded by evil warriors.
Could you, perhaps,
help me one last time?
Clear out the soldiers at the far end of this passage,
if it pleases you.
The Lord's Path, just down yonder, has degenerated into a feeding ground for flying dragons.
Have your wits about you."
"Thank you. That makes twice.
Thanks to you, I can now forge ahead."
In Boletaria, they speak of the two swords; "Demonbrandt" and "Soulbrandt".
One banishes that which befouls men, and the other banishes men himself.
Dropped into the world along with the Old One, they seemed to symbolize the battle between man and his demons.
Soulbrandt, the sword that grows in power the more demonic the soul that wields it, is missing.
Ostrava is getting closer and closer to his father. Could it be that his father took up "that sword", the sword that banishes men?
"Help! Help! Soul-starved soldiers are after me!"
"Thank you for rescuing me."
"You saved my life... This is the third time, I am truly indebted to you."
"I must go.
My father, the king, awaits me just over there."
The sad truth is that, once, King Allant was a benevolent ruler who cared greatly for his subjects.
He fought diligently against the vile and the depraved.
Alas, as he aged he became melancholy.
Allant began a search for a method to expand his might.
His search brought him to the Nexus, where knowledge of the soul arts were bestowed upon him. This was not enough and eventually,
Allant awoke the Old One, which granted him unfathomable power.
This power,
devastated his human form,
transforming his body into a pathetic mutated creature.
This is not Allant, this is a magnificent
demon that Allant fashioned, a doppelganger designed to lead the demon scourge and reap more souls to quench the thirst of the Old One.
The real king resides within the Old One.
Believing that the Old One is a gift of mercy from God, in
his old age, Allant recognized that pain, evil and misery filled the world.
It was so hopeless, that the only way to fight poison, was with poison.
So Allant awoke the Old One, hoping for its deep fog to engulf the land and absorb every last soul.
Only then, did he believe that human suffering would end.
Despite all odds, Ostrava...
finally fights his way into his father's throne room. Past the soldiers who have had their souls stolen,
past the fat officials who torture and maim,
past the dragons defending the king's keep, and up the final steps of his journey.
Tragically, Prince Allant discovers that his father, has in fact, become a demon.
This is not quite the truth, as the real Allant resides within the Old One, but, either way it is true that Allant;
once a benevolent ruler, is indeed responsible for the demon scourge that wiped out humanity.
" Oh, it's you, is it?
My father is up above...
Well, what's left of him anyway...
He's transformed into a fiendish demon... I began this quest in a search for truth,
but it seems I was a fool to even try...
Please,
kill my father. In his degenerated state, he can only bring peril to the lands.
This key,
fits the Boletaria Mausoleum.
Inside the mausoleum are my father's two swords; Soulbrandt and Demonbrandt.
Use them to bring an end to this madness."
Overcome with despair, and before you can stop him, Ostrava kills himself in soul form.
His black phantom appears shortly after.
Ostrava found the truth, but it didn't bring him peace. His quest was for nothing,
yours wasn't.
"On the first day man was granted a soul
And with it, clarity"
For in man, great potential was seen.
Yet, "On the second day
upon Earth was planted
an irrevocable poison
A soul-devouring demon."
For like the demon, man had an insatiable, destructive appetite for souls.
- from "Demon's Souls Story ► Prepare to Cry Trailer"